okay also for the first time in 2019
today it is hatred mail what's hatred
mail hatred mail is when a professional
voice-over artist interprets horrible
emails that I get here's a quick
reminder about what hatred mail is hey
we'd probably poison our entire family
if Trump told us to but remember it's
not a cult patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom okay no
introduction needed for this the first
Patriot mail of 2019 let's take a listen
to it together and see if it makes any
sense at all David you are deliberately
trying to look gay with the crediting
Obama for Trump's economy you have
Jewish privilege David and a major bias
Park man the Jimmy Dore of the left
David Pakman is an anti white
anti-christian anti-gentile Jew how does
a gay Jew become alright David Pakman I
assume means how does it gauge you
become alt-right the funniest thing in
there Pat is I'm the jimmy dore of the
left I thought Jimmy was on the left or
at least ostensibly yes say what you
want about jimmy dore but he's
definitely left-wing i don't know what
that means here the jimmy dore of the
left yeah you're on the left and he's on
the left I'm not sure I mean certainly I
would take issue that he is on the same
left that I'm on I think that that would
be something we could talk about for it
for a long time if we cared to which we
don't
and also I'm deliberately trying to look
gay that would suggest I'm not but then
of course they say I am gay and just the
obsession with sexual orientation from
the hatreds continues to be bewildering
but what I can tell you today is that if
you are not on board with the message of
the hey treats if you want to send them
a message which says no no no your views
will not be tolerated
you can use the coupon code hey tree at
40 when you sign up for a membership on
our website h8
our IOT 4-0 that'll save you 40% off of
your membership and hatreds cry whenever
that coupon code is used